most of us
strive to lose weight but these people
might be actively trying to gain it
if they continue to eat this much food
they could end up
weighing up to 500 pounds
now gaining 5 to 10 pounds during the
holidays is
one thing but gaining 300 pounds
usually happens gradually after years of
bad habits combined with other factors
but how about we speed up that process
and have you
gain 300 pounds in just one year
what kind of health problems could you
expect
this is your body on gaining 300 pounds
in one
year rapid weight gain is when you put
on
a large amount of weight in a short time
and that's what we'll be doing today
most people would find it a challenge to
gain
100 pounds in a year but we'll be
gaining
300 pounds what would you need to do
to accomplish this could it be eating a
mountain of mcdonald's every day
cancelling your gym membership or both
let's find out so you're trying to gain
300 pounds in a year that breaks down to
25 pounds
a month there are many factors that
contribute to rapid weight gain
let's start with an obvious one diet
one study concluded that eating 1 000
extra calories a day for 5 days did not
lead to significant weight gain however
eating 1
000 extra calories a day for a month
led to a weight gain of about three
pounds
and increased blood sugar that's like
eating
seven or eight big macs a day for 30
days
but those are rookie numbers to reach
your goal of gaining 25
pounds a month you would need to
quintuple that amount of calories
wow that's a lot of big macs
okay by now you've gained 25 pounds
in addition to eating thousands and
thousands of calories of junk food
you've also incorporated a second
element into your weight gain journey
and that's eliminating exercise
you won't even be able to walk as that
expense too many calories for this
challenge
you may feel a little sluggish but the
extra weight hasn't affected you too
much yet
okay now you've gained 75 pounds
you've begun to notice it both in how
you feel
and look a third and unexpected
contributor to weight gain
is lack of sleep we burn calories
while we sleep so to stay on track with
our weight gain
you're going to need to sleep the bare
minimum a human needs
leading you to feel more and more
exhausted
now you're feeling it with 150 extra
pounds
how could you not you're tired all the
time
you don't recognize yourself and you're
on the path to some
serious health problems you know a
fourth element that plays a role in
rapid weight gain
is genetics if you want to complete this
challenge in time
your genetics will have to be pretty bad
at least
when it comes to keeping your weight off
according to the harvard medical school
more than 400 different genes can
contribute to obesity
these genes affect things like appetite
metabolism and
feeling full so not only are you
always craving large quantities of food
that are
high in trans fats carbs and sugar but
your stomach is a bottomless pit and
your metabolism
can't keep up over 12 months
you managed to combine all the factors
eating tons of junk food
not exercising not sleeping enough and
bad genetics and you met your 300 pound
goal
now what well putting on that much
weight would make it hard to move
or walk your bones would have
trouble supporting you you'd likely be
diagnosed with some significant health
problems like
heart disease diabetes or cancer
even breathing can become difficult plus
obesity is linked to depression and low
self-esteem
so you'd not only be physically
unhealthy but
possibly mentally unhealthy as well that
doesn't sound like much of a life at all
in general gaining a large amount of
weight in a short amount of time
is not a healthy or safe thing to do and
therefore not worth it but if you want
to gain weight in a healthy way by
say using weight training to build
muscle slowly over time then
yeah give it a try but you won't gain
300 pounds in a year this way
and that's a good thing you may be game
to gain 300 pounds in one year but we
don't recommend it
i think it's time to go on a health kick
let's try
going vegan for a year think you're up
for it
well we'll see what the challenge brings
on another episode
of your body on